hey guys bandit here i recently stumbled
upon a very very telling little detail
in the game files of security breach and
as all fnaf theorists know the little
details are normally pretty big deals if
that wasn't true we would never know
that baby was elizabeth afton anyway
this particular discovery was brought to
my attention literally earlier today i
was literally working on a completely
different theory about vanessa and vani
being two different people and
explaining this confusing ending of the
game that i planned on going live with
today but stumbling upon this fact this
morning has just thrown everything out
the window and gotten me super excited
and confused remember that quirky little
zelda light game located on three
different arcade machines scattered
throughout the mega pizzaplex called
princess quest well up until about a
month ago when this reddit post was made
which i didn't see until this morning
everybody assumed that princess quest
was about this rather royal looking girl
here who begins her adventure in a
castle-like setting like a princess i
mean it made sense right but that reddit
post revealed to us that according to
some file diving this character this
golden girl venturing bravely through
the darkness fending off evil rabbit
abominations has a name it's cassidy you
heard me as in golden cassidy freddy of
the five original murdered children from
the original missing children's incident
who were all murdered in the 80s by
serial killer william afton and to top
things off in her princess quest
appearance she is literally golden i
know i know this is crazy so how is this
supposed to make sense now see the only
thing to do in my opinion is start over
and piece together things related to
cassidy over the franchise one by one
and i'm pretty sure we'll see that the
resulting answer is pretty simple once
we do to recap and refresh everyone's
memory of the names of the missing
children's incident or mci kids since it
has admittedly been several years since
all of this was brought to light the
names of the original kids were gabriel
fritz suzy jeremy and cassidy who
possessed the animatronics freddy foxy
chica bonnie and golden freddy
respectively also keep in mind this is
only according to the games and not
taking the novels into account which
only really served to kind of shuffle
the lore around a little bit and rarely
give us any straight answers as far as
the game's lore is concerned all of the
children's spirits except for gold and
freddies were released from their
animatronic prisons at the end of fnaf 3
when you see their masks in front of you
no longer glowing which they were in the
bad ending indicating that they have
found their piece at long last due to
the events leading up to the good ending
however if you contrast the good ending
with the bad ending once again you'll
notice that there is a freddy mask
behind the four that would be the fifth
animatronic golden freddy whose eyes are
lit up just like the rest of them but in
the good ending though the four
animatronic masks in front are cleansed
of spirits the fifth one behind them is
missing golden freddy cassidy is not yet
at rest this is speculated to be because
cassidy is the vengeful spirit extremely
angry at afton for his murders the one
who he should not have killed but we'll
get to that in a sec speaking of afton
after he burns at the end of fnaf 3 he
somehow survives as shown by this
cutscene from sister location which
ironically you have to complete a custom
night under the preset golden freddy to
unlock hint hint although golden freddy
himself does not actually appear in the
game it does however seem to connect the
two and foreshadow some lore fast
forward to the pizzeria simulator or
fnaf 6 which featured afton once again
showing up as scrap trap having survived
burning previously as springtrap at the
end of this game afton's ex-partner
henry emily burns down the location
presumably killing scrap trap and
michael afton and baby and molten freddy
and lefty and himself which would have
been a really nice ending to the series
all things considered but you know
popular money-making franchises never
really die anyway to bring this back to
cassidy and golden freddy it is widely
speculated that after these fiery events
transpire cassidy may have prevented
william afton from dying completely so
that she could torture him for all
eternity in the hell known as ultimate
custom night where we actually play as
the murderer afton himself this is
seemingly proven by many of the
animatronics speaking to the player
character as if they are resentful
against him often saying hateful things
and making references to quote the one
you should not have killed
[Laughter]
which if you use a bit of logical
deduction contrasting with the original
five mci victims and the golden one
that's still alive and more supernatural
and powerful than the rest and who was
linked to afton survival by way of
sister location's golden freddy custom
night preset
it's pretty obvious that cassidy golden
freddy is william afton's tormentor the
one he should not have killed and
ironically the reason why afton's spirit
does not actually disappear even after
dying to a springlock suit and burning
several times so that's the recap and
everything we know about golden cassidy
friday leading up to security breach in
a nutshell besides the supernatural
animatronics brief appearance in fnaf ar
special delivery but there's really not
much more to gather there other than
just simply an appearance from the
character cassidy's name showing up as
the protagonist character in the
princess quest games could actually work
since we don't have a confirmed ending
to golden freddy yet so obviously it was
clear to all of us that we would be
seeing the entity again right the
question is of course how is this golden
freddy and what is the connection
between golden freddy and vanni of all
people who has a completely different
backstory relating to afton as far as
cassidy getting somehow uploaded into a
digital game goes that's something
that's left up to complete speculation
at this point and i'm pretty sure we
have like literally nothing to go off of
but my personal headcanon for this is
that golden freddy somehow had its
circuit board scanned in to either the
fazbear virtual environment or one of
the arcade games since the princess
quest minigame does actually appear in
help wanted mobile but that's neither
here nor there so let's switch gears and
talk about vani real quick we know from
help wanted's ending that vani is most
likely the protagonist player character
who we can hear speaking to glitch trap
aka william afton who was mistakenly
scanned into the game as a virus which
is a whole other storyline that i'll
cover in just a sec veni appears to don
her signature mask but then ends up
being locked inside a virtual reality
room on the other side of a very
peculiar looking door indicating that
her mind or possibly the sane part of it
is locked away inside a digital prison
this is most likely the reason why vani
is a follower of glitch trap but yet is
freed from her psycho shackles if you
complete all three princess quest games
and unlock this ending where she leaves
her vani costume behind to eat some ice
cream on a hill now let's quickly go
back to that part where i mentioned
afton was scanned into the game help
wanted this happened as proven by emails
from fnaf ar because the developers of
the game wanted to place the original
fnaf games inside of this game in hopes
of masking the actual events and
pretending they were always just games
just a little bit of an in-universe lore
retcon event if you will and hoping to
expedite the process of development and
therefore save on time and resources
they began to scan in the circuit boards
of the old animatronics to their system
one of which was the burned remains of
scrap trap but even though scrap trap
was burned and unusable it still had the
spirit of william afton bound to it due
to cassidy's desire to torment him and
not let him go and when the
broken-bodied scrap trap circuit board
was scanned in it gave the spirit of
afton attached to it a new body if you
will in the form of fazbear's virtual
environment giving him free roam within
the digital world leading to vanity's
corruption and the events of security
breach as a whole
and what makes us even worse and
connects it to cassidy is the fact that
most likely this would not have happened
if cassidy would have just released her
rage and allowed william afton to move
on like her friends did but her
unbridled unholy anger towards her
murderer prevented her from allowing
this and thus william afton's
resurrection as glitch trap and the
furthering of the five nights at
freddy's storyline is all cassidy's
fault and i'm not pulling this out of
thin air either this is more or less
confirmed by a tiny little character
known as old man consequences who first
appeared in fnaf world but ultimately
came back with lore implications in
ultimate custom night in the game if you
set every animatronic level to zero but
old man consequences to one you'll
eventually get a pop-up of the character
fishing on screen if you press the
button to catch the fish and do it
properly you'll be transported to a
different mini-game you play as what is
unmistakably a freddy fazbear icon which
given the game we're playing presumably
means you're playing as golden freddy
cassidy though it's not completely
confirmed due to everything being
monotone but
come on it's golden freddy if you walk
up to him and speak to him he'll tell
you this come and sit with me a while
leave the demon to his demons rest your
own soul there is nothing else knowing
that ultimate custom night is a hell for
william afton and old man consequences
is talking to cassidy we can assume that
the demon he is talking about is william
afton and that the old man is warning
cassidy to leave it alone and rest her
own soul but as we know she didn't you
can play it over and over again because
she holds on being unwilling to release
afton from this hell which ultimately
led to afton's glitchy revival so here's
my explanation piecing all of this
together what if cassidy knows what she
did either because of old man
consequences warning or just because of
observance what if she knows that now
afton her eternal nemesis equals glitch
trap which equals vani and that it's all
her fault but also that vani is just
being possessed and there's still hope
for her and this is why cassidy embarks
on her quest not to doom the demon but
to save the princess also known as her
princess quest and just like the zelda
games that this series of minigames is
based off of the name princess quest not
actually being about the protagonist
character cassidy actually lines up with
the legend of zelda not being about the
protagonist's character link also when
you do finally approach the glitch trap
door at the end of princess quest 3
notice the location of the lock it's on
the left side the last view that we were
given of the store was when the lock was
on the right side meaning this is a
different angle and vani is on the other
side of the door giving credence to the
notion that this is not vani but rather
cassidy releasing vani from within her
confinement vani is for all intents and
purposes not only the right hand of
afton but may as well even be afton so
defeating vanny if you will would in
actuality be golden freddy defeating
glitch trap or cassidy defeating afton
and it makes sense in a beautiful kind
of way now whether or not this means
afton will stay dead i'm not sure it's
possible that at the time of releasing
vanie from her prison afton may have
already been transferred into burn trap
and it also depends on which ending of
the game is actually canon but until
something else is revealed to us by way
of dlc and we're able to confirm or
deconfirm everything i talked about in
this video this will remain just my
theory but what did you guys think is
golden freddy cassidy the savior of vani
and defeater of glitch trap redeeming
her mistakes for keeping afton alive or
is this literally just another cassidy
with no lore implications whatsoever let
me know in the comments below also thank
you so much for watching the first fanaf
video on the channel regarding the
mysterious client 46 from the retro
series was really successful in terms of
my videos and i wouldn't have been brave
enough to try covering this franchise
again if it wasn't for the great turnout
so thank you all so much for watching it
and if you haven't checked it out yet
i'll link to it in the description below
please consider leaving a like if you
enjoyed my second deep dive into fnaf
lore and subscribe if you haven't
already to stick around for the next
deep dive humongous thanks of course to
my bandit crew who are ultimately the
reason i keep making these videos and
that's about all i had for this one as
always i hope you have a wonderful rest
of your day this is massington abandoned
looking forward to seeing you next time
and signing out peace
[Music]
you